yes and Fabiano we saw this position you
play original position with the move b5
tell us about this preparation yeah b5
is a relatively new line but it's pretty
well known by now it's been played by a
lot of strong players this year even
appreciate played it I think a few games
with this so it's a very legitimate
bicycle chance maybe it was rapid but
it's been played a lot in classical just
as well I mean it's a very legitimate
locker block all right well he got a
position you said he liked what did you
feel you were in any danger particularly
around the point when he decided he
wanted to thrust at f4 f4 came as a huge
relief because I thought my position is
dangerous if he just plays an ID for
Bishop f3 Queen e2 and kind of takes it
slow but f4 I thought can't be a good
move I mean it's it's probably not a bad
move but I think it does relieve some
pressure on me and I thought my d4 and
I'm Bishop f3 and Queen e2 and the plan
being what
well after Queen e2 I can consider
Bishop a trough queen g4 and some sort
of attack if I don't have any moves owns
gonna be tough for me I think what he
wants to avoid was an ID 5 Bishop f3 and
then maybe who's worried about Knight
takes c3 but here I think a knight takes
c3 is strong they should go 3 G of 3 and
then my knight only thought is just very
weak so I actually shouldn't take 1 of 3
I think I should try to play like Bishop
d5 or something or work up to you the
previous movie I should keep keep the
blockade but anyway f4 was a relief and
then I thought I had a reasonable
position well you got to this position
we we didn't pepper him with the
question what we're curious about your
opinion on this he said that he didn't
play for g4 and and 5 after you played
rook b5 because he forgot that your
knight is hanging on a5 were you worried
at all about the moment g4 you know I
mean I thought that I should have decent
time to play in case he doesn't even
like this but maybe it's possible I mean
I do have a lot of options here I guess
but the position is so messy that that
it's hard to say exactly how I should
play but maybe Queens d6 or something
I'm not mad
and so I'll bring up a variation for you
it's a completely computerized variation
and I I guess intuitively you didn't
look at g4 at all but there's this line
with the rook to b8 and if f5 you can
actually take on b2 and we're going to
throw in a couple of moves just because
we were having fun with it and Bishop f8
and then after Queen a5 is every three
there you go
candidate well this this this shows why
g4 is sort of a weakening move but
that's very beautiful yeah that's pretty
tactic and also the Queen gets trapped
up through p3 if he trusts to move the
bishop or something which is nice
rook takes any three also Trump's the
Queen right so you would have looked a
little bit and found as a little wrinkle
maybe I don't know it's such a messy
position but I I think with g4 white
takes on a great degree of risk as well
you declined to draw when it was
possible to repeat what's your thoughts
there I thought I I mean I didn't think
I was better but I thought my position
is comfortable and I mean I just wanted
to play a bit more he he seemed happy to
repeat and I felt I mean this a type of
at first I didn't take too seriously but
then I started looking at it again it
seemed pretty good I just stopped him
from playing a5 a6
which would be a very strong pawn and I
and after I get rid of this idea he
doesn't have any ideas it's still of
course equal because I can't do much but
I thought black is on the better side of
equality he made this comment that he
thinks you should do this because you're
gonna be playing it's Magnus and this is
the kind of thing that will happen
you'll have to potentially milk some of
these kind of foolish positions was that
a thought for your own I mean if I got
the same position I probably played
against Magnus as well but I mean I I
think that in general you have to try to
take your chances you know you don't win
games every day in these tournaments
winds usually come with a great deal of
difficulty and and so if you get any
slightest chance you have to try to take
it I tried in this game all right well
thank you very much for the effort and
we look forward to seeing you win goblet
he's taking the most of your chances
thank you a great effort indeed Abby
keep up keep it up it will happen I mean
something good is going to happen and we
have one game remain